and as you know oh this is great as you
know we and I do mean we I've been
trying to get President Obama on the
show for a long time but now my dream
was to have him here in the studio with
you our studio audience maybe next time
for that but for the interview tonight
we were thrilled to be invited this week
to the Roosevelt Room in the White House
where the president was I have to tell
you that the president was
extraordinarily generous with this time
I wanted to ask him the kind of
questions that we crazy people favorite
real time might be interested in the
kinds of questions he doesn't often get
and two of those we saved to tempt you
to see more of the interview online at
youtube.com slash real time where you
can see me ask the president about
atheism and about why does America need
to have an empire but right now here is
the president three days ago at the
White House okay
okay with the president we're very
excited to be here I'm very grateful
thank you very much you must be a little
wistful you must feel a little like
David Ortiz about a month ago where you
know you're you're going on to great
things in the next chapter of your life
so I'm hitting and you're still hitting
but my feet are but but you know you'll
never quite have a job as exhilarating
well you know it it is time you know I
tell people that this has been a great
run I have loved this job I'm not going
to pretend that there haven't been
moments of great frustration but it is a
singular privilege I think I'm as good a
president now as I've ever been because
you learn stuff yeah eight years you've
sort of been around the track a bunch of
times but I also see now the wisdom of
the founders that at a certain point you
have to let go
for the democracy to work so we're a
week out from the election and I you're
a history buff
I think if when we look back if mr.
Trump is defeated I'm hopeful that we
will be the take away will be that
socialism was not such a dirty word
anymore because of our friend Bernie
Sanders and I just wondering why someone
who was accused of being a socialist
before what you think about the idea
that in America yes we're capitalists
but some things just should not be for
the profit motive health care prisons
the military elections and I would add
newsgathering people say get the money
out of politics I think you got to get
out of the news business first or we're
never gonna learn anything well a couple
things I said first of all in some ways
the label socialism doesn't make that
much sense in a context where there's no
economy that doesn't have some socialist
elements meaning that there's some
common goods that we all agree everybody
should have mm-hmm that's what Social
Security is that's what Medicare is to
some extent that's what public schools
are we all chip in to make sure that
everybody no matter the circumstances
your birth have these baseline Goods and
as you know I felt pretty strongly that
health care should be one of those one
of those goods I've also said in the
past that if I were designing a system
from scratch I would have probably
looked at a single-payer system but we
do have legacy systems and and that's
the only thing that sometimes when I've
had conversations with Bernie
I've said to them yeah we don't start
from scratch there there you've got a
one trillion dollar health care industry
for example and you got a lot of people
who are working for it and a lot of
special interests involved and so my
goal in the Affordable Care Act was if I
can get millions of more people
insurance then that's my first goal and
then the question is how do we make sure
everybody ultimately gets it because
there's still gaps in coverage
I think the same is true you know when
it comes to some other issues to me I
think there is a pretty bright line
around prisons I agree with you that the
criminal justice system should not be
infected by that the profit motive
this is the awesome power of the state
saying we can take somebody's freedom
away we can lock them up because they've
breached some part of the social
contract
the notion that you want in you might
incentivize people to lock more people
in or keep them there longer or not
provide the kind of rehabilitation
services so that they can get out of
there I think that's a problem and so
I'm very proud of some of the work that
we've been trying to do along these
lines
we got more work to do when it comes to
the media at the you know that's a
tougher call because look state-run
media that's what they got in and not
state-run but just like it used to be
where it was a lost leader for that for
the network's they didn't have to make a
profit because they had a monopoly
though to some degree right right so
they were fat and happy in this kind of
environment it's hard to figure out how
you would do that but you know the I
think the question I'd have when it
comes to the media is how do we create a
space where truth gets eyeballs it is
entertaining and we can build a common
conversation at what is true when I
leave here one of the things I'm most
concerned about is the balkanization of
the media where you've got 800 stations
you got all these websites people have
difficulty now just sorting out what's
true and what's not
yeah and if you don't have some common
baseline effects yeah you we can have a
disagreement about how to deal with
climate change but if we have a big
chunk of the country that you share just
discounts what 99% of scientists say
completely it's very hard to figure out
how we
move the democracy forward okay let me
ask you about a question that I know
people who watch our show we're
interested in which is marijuana reform
is that something that you care about I
did something like care about this now
we both made jokes about it but it's not
funny to the people who get arrested
yeah which is over half a million I
think last year you know you and I both
could have had our lives ruined not
really by smoking it but by being
arrested for it right and you know I
feel like you had a checklist about
let's get rid of a lot of the stupid
stuff like opening up Cuba you know you
came out for gay marriage
I was hoping ending the drug war would
be on that list it's on the ballot now
in nine states in a week
including California for recreational
and Arizona and medical in places like
North Dakota isn't it time the federal
government caught up to progressive
states like Arizona and North Dakota
well here's what I mean I have always
believed that to the extent that the
society legitimately wants to guard
against any kind of substance abuse that
you treated as a public health problem
look I'm an ex-smoker
cigarette smoker x.x and really yeah I
really anchor did you get something
right there I thought I caught a wink
I'm chewing the heck out of nicorette
really
but no what I when I passed health care
reform that was I think right I'd had my
last cigarette but but the reason is
because there was this enormous public
health effort to get kids not to pick up
smoking and to make sure that parents
felt guilty if if they were passing on
that that habit to their kids and I and
so that's where I think we need to go
with pot alcohol and so so I don't think
that legalization is a panacea but I
think that we're going to have to have a
more serious conversation about how we
are treating marijuana and our drug laws
generally okay I want to ask you this
question again it's an issue I think you
don't get asked a lot about but it's
important to my audience I know people
will roll their eyes and say it's so
California to ask this but food purity
yeah something that means a lot to me
somehow it got to be elitist or liberal
I don't get that - womp food that isn't
full of pesticides of food that wasn't
created by torturing animals and factory
farms isn't full of antibiotics which is
a problem in itself I feel like we're
upside down on food we eat too much corn
because we grow too much corn because we
subsidize too much corn and you know one
of the problems with the Affordable Care
Act is that people were found sicker
right then expected and that's partly
birth of the food I think and obesity
and all the work that Michelle's been
doing yeah yeah well shouldn't the food
be put more at the top of the agenda
when when we come to addressing health
care there's no doubt about it that
right now we got a disease care system
we should have a health care system and
health care system would include
nutrition exercise but also pushing back
on corporal and and and so yeah I think
what is true is that for a long time
agribusiness has and a obviously a
prominent seat of the table in Congress
it's bipartisan some of the reforms that
we've tried to initiate for example on
the school lunch program have actually
made some progress on this front and
Michelle deserves a lot of credit for it
as do a bunch of organizations that have
worked on this I will tell you and this
may be controversial in some your
audience it is important to look at the
science on this stuff so when it comes
to antibiotics for example the science
is clear we pump our animals full of it
and and that's not just a problem in
terms of what we're ingesting it's also
a problem that more and more you know
bacteria is becoming resistant to
antibiotics but in some cases like for
example the GMO debate there are there
are areas where there are legitimate
concerns there are some areas where the
science seems to indicate well this is
okay we hand out back to the same said
it says it doesn't increase the yield
well
exact hadn't they use just as many if
not more pesticide well that's so so my
point is what that what we have to be
make sure we're doing whether we're on
the left or the right is being driven by
the science and if it turns out that
some of these genetically modified foods
aren't healthier aren't more productive
and use more pesticides then we should
follow the science if in some cases
they're not causing any harm then we
should follow the science there as well
do you think we ask too little of the
public politicians you know of course
they're always kissing up to the public
and saying things like if we only had a
government as good as the people but the
people aren't very well informed they
don't exercise the right to vote and
when they do they don't know much about
it and just feel like we don't we don't
ask the people very much we're afraid to
ask the people eat better you know that
the phrase was yes we can't and I feel
like they're not pulling their weight on
the we it's a partnership with those
yeah eat better vote more learn
something you know I I'm a
glass-half-full guy
and an optimist about the human spirit
you are right though that people are
busy they're stressed and they don't
have time to follow the intricacies of
some debate around Medicaid or you know
what's going on in Syria and so part of
that what when I say I want a government
as good as the the American people what
I mean by that is is that I think
people's instincts their gut what they
what they want out of life and how they
want to see people treated is actually
pretty good but the question then
becomes how do we get enough information
in front of them to be able to make good
decisions I've always believed that if I
could get into you know if I could sit
in the living room with every person in
America over you know that I've got the
majority on my side and a healthy
majority on my side on every issue that
we work on just by having a conversation
the problem is we got all these filters
and look if I watched Fox News I
wouldn't vote for me either right right
because you know you've got this screen
this funhouse mirror through which
people are receiving information how did
how to break through that is a big
challenge this whole conversation that's
been had lately in in the aftermath of
the rise of Trump this notion that part
of what's happened is is that both
Republican and Democratic elites have
neglected the white working-class men
truth of the matter is is that every
policy I've put forward would make a
huge difference with the white
working-class and the black working
class and the Latino working class
whether it's raising the minimum wage or
the affordable care act given people
health care who don't have it and we're
working hard and need help or making
sure that unions are strong so that you
could have a little more leverage at the
workplace or making sure that you know
something like the consumer finance
Protection Bureau
is may is protecting against some scam
mortgage and what I'd like to figure out
and I think Democrats do have an
affirmative obligation to do that do
this is to work harder to to figure out
in this new age what's the equivalent of
getting into people's living rooms and
being able to have a conversation and
being able to listen to people and okay
now you're off to Ohio right you've got
an election to rig and I want you I want
you to get out there because boy it's
it's a very nervous time for a people
who are worried about mr. Trump
the stakes are high I I know we you know
we're getting the we're getting the
we're getting the gone but but but but I
will say this the choice in this
election is should be really clear and
and anybody who's watching your show and
was a supporter of mine was a supporter
of Bernie's you know is a progressive
generally this idea that somehow well
you know both of them have problems and
yeah nothing will change either listen
all the progress we've made on climate
change Paris agreement HFC agreement
Aviation Agreement the 20 million people
who have health insurance that right now
that didn't have it before all the
progress that we've made on trying to
check the excesses Wall Street and
dodd-frank and the and consumer finance
Protection Bureau any chance of
immigration reform including the work
that we did to make sure that these
amazing dreamer kids all across the
country who are now going to college or
serving in our military are not suddenly
deported or at risk of deportation
every single issue that we've made
progress on over the last eight years is
gonna be on the ballot in the form of
this choice and I have worked with
Hillary Clinton I know her
and she is somebody who cares about
these issues she does her homework she
cares deeply about ordinary folks her
policies are aligned with yours and mine
and yes she is somebody who believes in
compromise and that you don't get a
hundred percent of what you want but you
know what that's the way this democracy
works
anybody sitting on the sidelines right
now or deciding to engage in a protest
vote that's a vote for Trump and that
would be badly damaging for this country
and it would be been damaging for the
world so yeah no no complacency just to
get out there get out there thank you so
much did a hell of a job in this office
I know I speak for most often though
I'll bet you did this no I wasn't on the
show that often I watched it all the
time really thank you well that's nice
to hear
Thank You mr. president all right
you